head over to the best song ever.com and
purchase our new hit together again it
is a cover of smoky Mike in the god king
that's Jeremy boring and Michael nolles
and with your help we will smash our way
onto the Billboard charts let's go to a
very difficult subject abortion all
right uh so have on your uh website here
this is maran2 24.com
100% pro-choice uh do you want to just
break down for us what your view is on
abortion what it should be ACC I think
abortion is a moral
issue but I think it is a moral issue
that is between a woman and her
conscience the god of her understanding
um I believe it is an issue of private
morality and not public morality uh
traditionally in this country uh The
Divide between right and left people on
the right concern themselves more with
issues of private morality people on the
left issues of public morality like uh
that's why you find people on the right
talking about abortion talking about
homosexuality people on the left talking
about economic Justice is a moral issue
invading a country that didn't do
anything to you as a moral issue it's
kind of inverted now though well the
Democrats are pro you know funding for
Ukraine and well but see Republicans are
anti me even that that's a comp can we
just get more real and more deep about
it rather than seeing it they're doing
it with Israel and Palestine too
everything people are trying to make
everything black and white now well you
said Republic the right tends to do this
the left tends to do that and I would
say l specific issues I didn't mean but
are we going to stay with abortion yeah
yeah for sure okay I just feel I trust
the uh moral decision- making of the
American woman and I don't think a
government has any right to tell a woman
what to do with her body do you think
there should have be any limits on uh uh
the amount of like how many weeks yeah
and the states came up with those limits
and that's why I think what we had with
roie way was reasonable so uh in your
view do you do you think it should be a
federally legislated or codified issue
pertaining to abortion that should
affect all states like roie Wade for
instance was
overturned as president would you
advocate for or sign a bill that would
federally codify roie way yes do you
think that there should be uh limits uh
how do you phrase this properly should
there be a time limit like after 16
weeks or 21 well there always was there
was there was but do you think there
should be now is there is there ex when
Yes except when the health of the health
of when health issues of Health are
involved so look so uh let's say there's
no issue of Health a woman is pregnant
would it be what what's what's your view
16 we when people start talking about
this late term abortion thing you've got
no do I think someone who a a woman
who's eight months pregnant just decides
you know I don't want to do this should
she be able to have an abortion no but
that doesn't happen so then would you
have an issue with it being made
illegal well well it it was during the
during when roie Wade was
legal that was not possible the states
had the states had their their their
limits if if a republican Congress said
okay it never happens we're going to ban
all abortions after six months no
because you've got to keep it with
medical I mean when you see what's
happening with Kate Cox in Texas now I
don't think a government should get
between a a woman and medical
decisions this is the first I've heard
of Kate Cox but I think Tim's looking it
up right now yeah Texas Tribune Kate
Cox's case reveals how far Texas intends
to go to enforce there judges saying
what that woman has to do and she has to
leave Texas to get an abortion that was
necessary and that was uh for her health
and for her the the viability of her uh
being a being fertile in the future ah
yes but this was I believe the Supreme
Court ruled the doctor did not
demonstrate a medical need the doctor
the doctor that's the a a bunch of men
who are judges in Texas should not be
determining what the doctor calls
medical need and what the do what the
doctors were claiming was that her
future fertility was at stake yeah so
that's not for a bunch of judges in
Texas to say you therefore have not
demonstrated NE medical need because
they don't consider that a medical issue
and then this is what kills me why most
of my conservative friends say we don't
want government overreach to me that's
extraordinary government overreach that
was an issue of about that woman and her
medical care and those old men and and
on some Court in Texas saying that's not
I wouldn't I wouldn't go that far but I
do I do uh think when it comes to
medical issues it it's being debated
right now conservatives saying it's uh
Tri uh TR 18 or something like that I'm
I'm not familiar with the uh uh the
ailment of the child and they're
concerned that it could uh negatively
impact her uh fertility and the child
may not even live that long there's a
possibility child could live long but
not they're not sure and so that's
that's that's a very it is a tough moral
position that I don't I that's tough for
me that's tough for me I just don't to
me it's not even tough to me it's
government get your hands out of this
but let's let's let's go back because
I'm going to I'm going to press you on
this if the Republican said if you think
lat term abortion elective late term
abortion ever happens then how about we
have a ban elective abortion after 6
months is hereby made illegal but they
that that is already under under roie
Wade that was already true under roie
Wade that was already true the states
had uh their limits and then beyond that
there had to do with with uh what a
doctor had to say sure but is that is
yes you would agree with a law Banning
abortion elective abortion after six
months I I don't want to give you the
set time frame you can choose whatever
time frame you want after after a
certain after a certain period of time
yeah my concern is with um the
definition of of what it means to be a
medical issue and how how do we how do
how do how do we protect against abuse
of the system I've never been been one
to say that potential crimes of an indiv
individual should then in infringe upon
someone else's rights for say like
medical care and I'm not talking about
elective abortion I'm saying you know if
a woman has a very serious disease and
is going to Hemorrhage or something and
the doctor's like ma'am you're not going
to make it we have to operate now I
think it's absurd to be like but that
would abort the baby so we got to talk
to a judge or something the concern
there however is there have been
instances where people have tried argue
mental health qualifies and have tried
to use that to get elective abortion it
may be rare but this is the concern
conservatives have and pro-life
individuals have is preventing abuse of
the system and abortion as contraception
no matter what law you pass there's
going to be abuse of the system I agree
so that's not a reason not to pass a
good law I I completely agree I
completely agree I think uh yeah the the
idea that some people will break the law
means that everyone must now abide by
this a har standard doesn't necessarily
the problem no that's ridiculous but
there are concerns for instance in
Colorado the new law now and I
understand what you're saying about roie
Wade currently abortion in Colorado is
one of seven states without any term
restrictions as to when a pregnancy can
be terminated it is uh colloquially
described as uh uh restriction and
Limitless abortion meaning a woman could
be without many any medical health issue
and at 9 months and legally get an
abortion and and and to the point of
birth so uh the famous example of this
was when um
uh I think it was rep Tran I could be
get your name wrong in Virginia argued
to a judge that a baby could be at the
point of birth and the doctor could
terminate the life of the baby under
Virginia's bill the bill didn't pass uh
Governor Northam gotten a lot of heat
over this I think I actually have the
the story yeah this is right here from
2019 Virginia governor faces backlash
over comments supporting late term
abortion Bill where whether
intentionally or not he actually
described postbirth abortion which is
not a real thing but but he basically
described just killing the baby in his
statement on radio he said the baby
would be delivered resuscitated and then
they would decide if they would like to
terminate come he did say that yes but
yeah but that does
not that and he said it's not a real
thing well no no no post post birth
abortion is just killing a baby yeah so
but that's what Northam actually
advocated for well it's absurd so this
this is this issue like this comes up in
the press and just like all the other
issues you'll end up with me like you
know traditional Li Al fairly pro-choice
but like I think there should be safe
legal rare and you see a story like this
and I'll say okay this man's lost his
mind you got to vote him out of office
then the media claims he never said it
they claim it's a lie they say nobody
wants this it never happens and we're
sitting here like we got the guy on his
his audio of him uh basically uh he says
they're done in cases where there may be
severe deformities I can tell you
exactly what would happen the infant
would be delivered the infant would be
kept comfortable the infant would be
resuscitated if that's what the mother
and the family desired and then a
discussion would ensue between the
physician and the mother oh so they're
talking about severely deformed
babies it we we can I will give him all
of the benefit of the doubt and
everything and we will say the most
deformed a baby could be he's still
talking about after it's already born
and Alive bring it to another room and
then talking with the doctor whether you
want to end its
life it's a question
of you know to what degree do we accept
deformities to be terminated after birth
right I mean this is his quote CNN has
it uh you know what is what is uh severe
deformity defined as legally I mean is
Down syndrome considered that to that
degree oh God
no but I mean one of the most common
forms of reasons for abortion is the
baby is diagnosed with down you know now
we have sonograms and we have um what is
that other one called uh not sonogram
the they know so much now do in your
opinion if a woman found out that her uh
her healthy viable pregnancy the child
had Down syndrome do you think that's
reason for an
abortion I would have the child I would
have a I would have a Down syndrome
child if I found out I had Down syndrome
but should it be legally allowed for a
woman to terminate a pregnancy that is
otherwise healthy if the child has Down
syndrome to me the issue of abortion
whether a whatever the woman's decision
has to do with the time and what that
state determines is the time so the and
then her reasoning is her reasoning so
any reason no reason at all until a
certain period of time no so like once a
child is viable and this is obviously a
baby they could be delivered and live
that's a whole different thing I
completely agree the argument we've
we've run into with progressives is they
actually go beyond that uh even a friend
of mine argued that a child a baby is
not alive until it's delivered therefore
a baby at 9 months could be aborted if
the woman l i don't agree with that a
lot of the progressives and it's not a
lot mind but I know I see this is where
we this this only bolsters and fortifies
this separation well progress I think
this is healing huh I think this is
healing that's why I ask uh hearing
hearing from you someone who's running
for for the Democratic party saying we
don't want these things is exactly what
I hope it is a moral issue of course
it's a moral issue this is what we need
I support roie way and I think a woman's
right to abortion should be codified by
law and I would do everything the idea
of a government telling a woman uh what
she has to do is very difficult for me
when I was uh uh when the roie way
decision came out I was more on the side
of perhaps it's good the states can
figure out for themselves and have more
nuanced laws but now I don't know if I'm
for roie Wade but I'm certainly for the
federal uh legislation and adjudication
of when a a baby has constitutional
rights so uh I believe life begins a
conception however I'm much more
libertarian on the issue which is why
I'm concerned about having to go to a
doctor or panel of judges to determine
medical issues it's it's tough I I don't
have a good answer but
uh excuse me I just lost my train of
thought we having a lot of we're hearing
everything that we said would happen
with DOs is already happening great
suffering among women you know women
used to have you know when I was growing
up it was simply before before roie way
um and I think I was a little girl at
the time but certainly before it was uh
legal it was about rich women getting
safe abortions and poor women getting
unsafe abortions thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 pm and become a member
over at timcast.net